cómo
x
[Aplausos]
hola que tal buenos días a todos
muchísimas gracias por venir para mí es
súper emocionante estar aquí con ustedes
y platicarles un poco de lo que hago de
quién soy y tratar de como buen chef
darle algún tipo de receta pero no sea
la receta perfecta porque creo que cada
quien tiene sus propias formas y sus
propias ideas pero es a lo largo de 19
años de dedicarme a los restaurantes y a
la cocina tengo unas libretas y me gusta
ir escribiendo y apuntando y me gusta
mucho hacer pláticas para estudiantes
como ustedes o para gente que quiere
emprender y siempre iba apuntando
diferentes ideas hasta que llegue a
hacer un decálogo como una receta de 10
pasos que a mi gusto es lo que han hecho
de pasar a tener un restaurante hace 15
años a tener hoy en día 17 restaurantes
y ya un grupo con casi 1000 personas
trabajando con nosotros
la primera que siempre yo trato de
decirle a la gente es tener esa parte de
fe ciega si a uno mismo esa parte de
creer yo abrí mi primer restante cuando
tenía 21 años empecé a trabajar a los 18
años cuando seguramente era incluso más
pequeña que ustedes
y tuve la oportunidad abrir mi propio
lugar a los 18 años a los 21 años ya
consiguiendo dinero en el banco
consiguiendo préstamos consiguiendo
vendiendo cosas que yo tenía para abrir
mi primer lugar y esa parte de fe ciega
y esa parte de tener esa convicción
personal y de confiar en uno mismo creo
que es la parte más importante para el
mes empezar un negocio siempre he hecho
que la parte económica es la parte más
fácil suena a veces un poco ridículo
decir eso pero cuando alguien quiere
emprender un negocio conseguir el dinero
se vuelve muchas veces lo más sencillo
cuando analizas todo lo que hay detrás y
de las cosas que más siempre nos atrasan
cuando queremos abrir un nuevo
restaurante una empresa es aparte de no
confiar en nosotros y decir es que nadie
va a confiar en mí nadie me va a creer
tengo 20 años como lo voy a hacer no me
van a dar
no me van a dar la razón le va a costar
muchísimo trabajo y esa parte que yo a
los 21 años me aventé y me arriesgué
porque realmente me voltea ahora al
espejo y decía es que quizás si lo puedo
hacer es que si lo puedo hacer y voy a
hacer todas las cosas para lograrlo
entonces aparte de fe ciega y creer en
nosotros mismos creo que es sumamente
importante cuando quieren emprender y
hacer un lugar como lo hice yo a los 21
años de compaq tsja
algo súper importante que yo lo vi
después de algunos años es que cuando a
los 21 años abrí packs ya que fue mi
primer restaurante y a los dos años de
abierto se convierte en uno de los
mejores restaurantes de todo el país y
yo a los 23 años
un chef reconocido y en esa parte en
donde te vuelves la gente que pueda ver
qué estás haciendo y te invitan a
congresos internacionales empiezas a
hacer muchísimas tonterías empiezas a
ser muchísimas pendejadas por así
decirlo empiezas a meterte en muchísimos
problemas y no valoras mucho las
consecuencias de lo que hay hasta que te
das es de golpe y te das cuenta que cada
decisión que empieza a tomar cuando
tienes un propio negocio las
consecuencias van a ser sumamente
importantes en tu vida y las
consecuencias de lo que hagas hoy van a
tener consecuencias muchísimo más
adelante y yo hasta la fecha sigo
pagando consecuencias de cosas que hice
hace 10 12 15 años y es bien importante
siempre analizar bien qué es lo que
quieren y pensar las consecuencias que
pueda tener esa decisión que tomen
cuando yo tenía 21 años y abrí pax ya me
tuve que rodear de gente era un
restaurante bastante grande el
restaurante de un local en san ángel que
tenía 800 metros de construcción
solamente me tuve que rodear de gente
siempre solo no podía yo estudiaba
administración en el itam pues de hecho
usted a la economía en el itam y después
me cambia estudia la administración en
el itam justamente para ver si podía
administrar mi propio restaurante cosa
que después de unos años me di cuenta
que no podía
pero me empieza a rodear de gente yo no
sabía cocinar en ese momento yo llevaba
trabajando tres años en restaurantes
pero la parte del de mesero de host en
la barra de repente no metía a la cocina
pero fue llegar a la cocina como de
botepronto y me tuve que rodear de
muchísima gente y ahí fue cuando entendí
que tienes que rodear de gente súper
capaz pero es bien importante siempre
favorecer el desarrollo de esa gente que
tienes contigo y no solamente favorecer
el desarrollo profesional porque muchas
veces siempre tenemos esa idea de que al
favorecer el desarrollo profesional de
alguien ascendiendo lo depuesto subiendo
lo de sueldo ya vamos a creer que es más
importante el el nivel va a seguir con
nosotros así cuando muchas veces la
parte del desarrollo profesional y un
puesto y un aumento en la tarjeta de
presentación en donde diga director en
vez de asesor o en vez de subdirector
acabando siendo tan importante yo me di
cuenta que el desarrollo personal es
muchísimo más importante de lo que es el
desarrollo profesional de nuestra gente
que es esto
hasta la fecha hoy cada vez que entra un
nuevo empleado nuestro me aprendo los
nombres sabemos las fechas de cumpleaños
s si alguno de sus familiares todo
alguno
hijos tienen algún problema de salud y
te acercas con ellos a preguntarles los
invito a mi casa nos vamos de viaje
juntos hacemos una parte en donde el
desarrollo personal se vuelve muchísimo
más importante que el desarrollo
profesional de la gente de nuestra
empresa y esto ha hecho que hoy en día
podamos tener 17 restaurantes y que la
gente realmente se sienta que trabaja
por lan tam como si tuvieran una familia
algo también relacionado con el punto 3
es que me encanta dejarlos tomar
decisiones a mi gente creo que las cosas
que más trabajo le cuestan a empresarios
a directores de empresas es confiar en
su gente y darles chance que ellos tomen
algunas decisiones darles tareas y algo
que aprendí muy bien es delegar esa
tarea supervisar esa tarea pero siempre
dejando muy muy muy en claro que el
responsable de la consecuencia el
responsable de lo que pase con esa
decisión que ellos tomen serán ellos y
que la repercusión será de ellos sea
buena o mala y eso es bien importante
que la gente esté enterada completamente
que toda decisión que tomen ellos serán
los responsables y así se sentirán
siempre parte del proyecto
importante rodearse de gente que cree en
ustedes cuando yo tenía 18 años y
comencé mi primer proyecto de
restaurante imaginan ser lo que era para
mí llegar a los 18 años con cocineros
que a lo mejor llevaban 25 o 30 años
trabajando en cocinas con restauranteros
que a lo mejor llevaban 10 años ya con
su propio restaurante y llegar a
venderles un proyecto mío cuando yo era
un pobre escuincle que apenas estaba
empezando y que había ya cambiado del
itam edad mis de economía administración
y que tenía cara de niño y que no sabía
nada de mí siempre fue súper complicado
pero siempre me agarré gente y les logre
enamorar de tal manera que el proyecto
los enamorara tanto que creyeran en mí y
que estuvieran a mi lado y que se
sintieran tan parte del proyecto que
pudiéramos crecer juntos y yo
convertirme en el jefe de alguien que
llevaba a lo mejor 20 años más que yo
cosa que creo que es bastante difícil y
más en un negocio como la cocina en
donde la rudeza en donde la experiencia
en donde la fortaleza que puedes tener
en donde los callos en las manos
literalmente y las quemadas te van
forjando muchísimo el camino y si
tuvieras un cocinero que no tiene
cicatrices en las manos incluso muchas
veces la gente no te da la razón y no te
dan o te toma en cuenta y era un
escuincle de 18 años que tuve que
agarrar gente que creyera en mí
algo importante y algo que me vaya
y hablar un poco más es esa parte de
decir inconforme muchas veces mi familia
incluso se burla de mí que me pasó de
inconforme que me pasó
nunca me gusta estar en el mismo lugar y
eso es esa parte que creo que nos ha
logrado hacer los restaurantes que
tenemos hoy en día cuando yo abrí packs
ya en el 2005 todos los recién egresados
de gastronomía los restauranteros
querían abrir restaurantes de comidas
francesas no si ustedes yo sé que son
más chicos que yo pero desde acuerden
hace 10 15 años los restaurantes famosos
en méxico eran de comida española de
comida francesa de comida italiana y
todos los nuevos jóvenes que querían
estudiar gastronomía y que salían
querían abrir un restaurante de esos y
llegó daniel ovadía a sus 18 años a
praia a proyectar un proyecto que
abriría tres años después de comida
mexicana cuando nadie estaba haciendo la
cocina mexicana después todo mundo
empezó alarmada en la cocina fusión no
sé si escuchado es una frase muy común
que decían la cosa de fusión es
confusión a mí me tocaba que mi abuela
cada vez que decíamos lo que vemos ahora
como bastante comida función decía es
que son es cocina y ahí va daniel ovadía
abrir un restaurante que se llama nudo
negro que se comida fusión mexicana con
asiática y todo mundo me tiraba de loco
y después cuando todo el mundo empezó
hacer cocina moderna y cuando todo mundo
empezó
cosas diferentes ahí vamos nosotros y
abrimos un restaurante de comida clásica
francesa en donde teníamos prensas de
pato y donde utilizábamos pura pura pura
cocina clásica sin utilizar nada de
tecnología y cuando todos decían que la
alta cocina mexicana era lo que tenía
que ir hoy decidimos abrir peltre que
era un restaurante que es un restaurante
una lonchería en donde su platillo más
famoso son los chilaquiles y todo el
mundo esperaba que daniel ovadía el de
pax ya que hacía cocina de autor y
grandes cosas estuviera haciendo
chilaquiles entonces esta parte de
inconforme y siempre creer más es lo que
me ha llevado a luchar y siempre buscar
nuevos proyectos y que me hizo salir de
su zona de confort de diez años de hacer
un restaurante de comida mexicana que ya
estaba consolidado como uno de los
mejores
de repente ponerme hacer cocina israelí
con merca va a hacer la lonchería con
peltre hacer la cocina función con nudo
negro hacer esa parte de cocina francesa
con french y hacer esa parte de un
restaurante el único restaurante en todo
el país que tiene ruedas y que se mueve
de los mochis a chihuahua todos los días
dentro del set de express esa parte de
inconformismo es lo que ha hecho
creemos estos proyectos nuevos y que
cada vez que empezamos el mes nos
sentamos en el día salvador ya que somos
los tres socios de holanda y decimos
hasta aquí le vamos a frenar y dos días
después agarramos un local nuevo y hoy
en día estamos abriendo un restaurante
en un hotel en que la condesa esa parte
de inconformidad y el nunca sentirse a
gusto en dónde estás creo que es lo que
ha logrado hacer quiénes somos hoy en
día en la parte de restaurantes
bien importante es nunca perder la
perspectiva ni olvidar quién eres ni de
dónde vienes yo les puedo platicar
anécdotas mías que a los 21 años pasa se
volvió un restante super famoso pax ya
cuando yo tenía 21 años bastante que
vendían millones de pesos al mes y que
yo era el único socio junto cuando
éramos tres socios y que nos dejaban
muchísimo dinero a los 21 años tuve la
oportunidad de ir a una agencia de
coches esports y tener la oportunidad de
comprar un porsche y saben qué pasó
después uno sea el más graso más grande
de la vida y uno tiene que aprender
todas las tonterías que hizo para jamás
volverlas a hacer y eso hace que 15 18
años después esté yo parado aquí y tenga
esa idea y esa perspectiva que jamás lo
voy a olvidar lo que pasó y las
consecuencias de lo que pasó es súper
importante que jamás se olviden de dónde
vienen jamás se olviden quién es su
familia jamás se olviden quién es la
persona que vieron en el espejo antes de
estar en donde estén cuando tengan éxito
porque cuando alguien se sube a su
ladrillo y se marea sea quien sea tenga
el dinero que tenga tenga la familia que
tenga tenga los conectores que tenga el
golpe que te va a dar la vida va a ser
completamente difícil y duro
efectiva jamás hay que olvidar la de
quién eres y adónde vas y a lo que mi
familia me enseñó mucho mi padre es
primera generación en méxico mi madre
segunda generación de mexico
y aún así estando parada donde estamos
hoy en día nos acordamos que mi abuelo
llegó en un barco de cáscaras de papas
méxico porque lo desviaron eeuu y
veracruz entonces la perspectiva jamás
hay que olvidarla y la parte que va muy
de la mano pues esa parte de las
perspectivas la parte de la humildad
pero durante la parte de la humildad de
vestirte con trapos no la parte humildad
de tener un coche barato ni la parte de
la humildad de tener un departamento
chiquito la parte de la humildad de
aprender a reconocer cuando algo pasa
mal en tu vida creo que es la parte de
humildad más difícil de tener cualquiera
puede ir a sara y se compra unos jeans
baratos cualquiera puede ir y en vez de
andar en coche propio está subiéndose en
un über o cualquiera puede ir e irse de
viaje en vez de la nueva york si pudiera
acapulco la parte más difícil de
encontrar en la vida de humildad está
esa parte en donde humildad con uno
mismo y reconocer los errores cuando
alguien la riega siempre cuando alguien
nos regañaba cuando reprobamos un examen
siempre tenemos ese pretexto con los
papás es que los demás también
reprobaron es que la maestra no explicó
bien es que no entré a esta clase y
siempre tenemos ese pretexto y cuando la
vida empieza a avanzar más ya no es tu 6
de calificación en un examen
son empleados corridos proxy caros sin
trabajo porque la empresa trono son
deudas con empresarios son deudas con la
hacienda son deudas con socios que
creyeron en ti y es aparte de tener esa
humildad contigo mismo y decir la regué
aquí va a ser que jamás vas a cometer
los mismos errores
algo bien importante que cuando uno es
joven y quiere emprender es súper fácil
ser un líder gritando es súper fácil ser
un líder dando únicamente órdenes y
estando con él
la cuerda dándole latigazos a la gente y
yo lo que aprendí a los 18 años con
entrar a una cocina fue que tenía que
ganarle a esa autoridad con respeto y
cómo se gana la autoridad con respeto
demostrado la tu gente que sabes hacer
las cosas demostrando la tu gente que
ellos están haciendo ese puesto pero
como tú como dueño lo puedes hacer y
xalbador y yo hasta la fecha llegamos a
nuestro restaurante y si vemos que un
cocinero está cortando mal el pescado
nosotros lo hacemos un la violencia mos
cómo cortar el pescado si vemos que un
mesero metió un plato vamos y le
enseñamos cómo meter el plato y no
únicamente le gritamos y le decimos como
hizo mal las cosas ni le marcamos horror
sino que le enseñamos a hacerlo y eso
nos ha hecho que una empresa con 1000
empleados tenga dos jefes de 35 y 31
años porque nosotros sabemos
perfectamente hacer cada puesto ellos
saben perfectamente que si un día
llegamos y la cocina está sucia saben
perfectamente que nosotros nos vamos a
poner los guantes y vamos a sacar el
ácido y vamos a limpiar la cocina junto
con ellos y vamos a desengrasar y nos
vamos a ir hasta las 4 de la mañana del
restaurante y de esta forma hemos
logrado tener esa parte de respeto en
donde mil personas respetan a los
escuincles de 35 años
la última que creo que es bien
importante y que a mí me pasó cuando
comienzas a tener éxito cuando comienzas
a tener tu propio negocio cuando te va
bien en la vida sientes que ya todo es
tuyo y vivimos en un mundo de inmediatez
simplemente antes de mí tuvimos a
alguien de uber tuvimos alguien de weiss
y qué es eso inmediatez completamente
inmediatez no también de boca hablaban
que hoy en día puedes ver la revista the
work en dvd medio oriente la puedes ver
en tu celular vivimos en un mundo en
donde queremos todo inmediatamente
queremos un libro a grabamos el celular
pedimos a amazon y nos llega un día
después pagamos 50 personas ya veces nos
llega hasta el mismo día y lo mismo
queremos que nos pase en la vida
empresarial que nos pase la vida como
restauranteros en la vida como
empresarios en todo que queremos que
todos llegue
y yo cuando tenía 24 años tenía 7
restaurantes y preguntarme a esos 24
años cuántos restaurantes siguen
abiertos hoy en día
ni uno ni uno porque por atrabancado y
por sentir que el mundo era mío y por
querer hacer todo en tres años abril
siete restaurantes y después quedó nulo
ninguno y en el 2010 pasamos la crisis
más fuerte que pudimos haber tenido
porque no tenemos nada y justamente fue
pensando en esa parte de inmediato es
decir me ofrecieron un restaurante acá
tengo un local allá me alcanza por abrir
otro lugar
y siempre tengan entendido las cosas
para llegar a su debido tiempo tengan
ganas de comerse el mundo completamente
pero con calma todas las cosas
relacionadas súper inteligentemente
porque todo va a llegar pero todo va a
llegar en su debido tiempo y todo se
hubiera acomodando cuando tiene que
llegar y no antes porque si no después
se acaba todo
y yo sé que no es el formato pero si
alguien quisiera algo en particular es
decir nos quedan 59 segundos
de adelante
pero de verdad muchísimas gracias que
cuando gusten estoy abierto en redes
para platicar me encanta hacer este tipo
de pláticas cuando me invitaron pude
haberles platicado de proyectos que
estamos haciendo en los restaurantes por
lo mejor hay gente aquí que está
estudiando no sé relaciones
internacionales y le vale saber si estoy
cocinando un pato 68 grados durante 12
horas y aún mando los 18 horas no creo
que era bien importante platicarles mi
experiencia como joven 35 años de lo que
ha logrado y prefería ser muchísimo más
esto espero que si uno de ustedes se
lleva esto a su casa y lo aplica creo
que ya me sentiré bastante contento de
haber estado con ustedes y muchísimas
gracias por haber estado
gracias